ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER* BATH [inaudible]
BONTA BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DEEP
[inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN.
GABRIEL GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY
[inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
REAVIS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
[inaudible]
STONE.
TEEN VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER.
WICKS.
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE HAVE SET OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER DOCTOR WEBER.
THANK YOU LETTERS BRAVE.
FATHER WHEN I WAS A KID.
I HEARD ABOUT THIS MAN WHO LIVE
NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE
YEARS.
NAME WITH THOSE LEFT.
AND THE ONLY THING THEY SAID WAS
HE LIVE NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
NINE YEARS.
AND THEN HE DIED.
IT A WE SPENT THE WEEKEND
HONORING THE LEGACY OF A MAN.
WHO LIVED ONLY THIRTY NINE YEARS?
BUT LOOK WHAT HE DID IN THIRTY
NINE YEARS.
AS WE REFLECT ON HIS WORK IT
BECOMES PROFOUNDLY CLEAR THAT
THIS YOUNG MAN.
AT THE AGE OF TWENTY SIX BECAME
A NATIONAL LEADER CARING THE
BURDENS OF RACE FOR HIS NATION.
AND THE WORLD.
AND THAT HE ONLY HAD THIRTEEN
SHORT YEARS TO DO THIS IMPORTANT
WORK.
BOB AS WE THINK OF OUR WORK.
BUT IS APPROACH WITH THE SAME
SENSE OF URGENCY IS DOCTOR KING.
MOST OF US HAVE ONLY TWELVE
SHORT YEARS.
ALMOST THE SAME AMOUNT OF TIME
IS DR KING HAD TO CHALLENGE AND
WIN SOME OF THE GREAT VICTORIES
OF THIS NATION.
LET US THE THESE TWELVE YEARS AS
KING YEARS.
AND USING WAS IF THERE WAS NO
OTHER TIME THAT FOR US TO
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES OF OUR
DAY. TO CORRECT SOME WRONG.
STRENGTHEN OUR STATE WHERE IT'S
BEEN CHALLENGING WEAKENED.
AND BUILD A FOUNDATION BASED ON
PRINCIPLES OF FAIRNESS JUSTICE
EQUALITY IMPROVED.
LET'S SUPPOSE THISIMPORTANT
WORK OF THIS ASSEMBLY AS DOCTOR
KING WITH A SENSE OF URGENCY.
AND A SENSE OF NOW.
SO THAT OUR LEGACY WOULD NOT BE
NEARLY ONE OF HAVING COUNTED ARE
TWELVE YEARS.
AND THEN LEAVING AS METHUSELAH.
LET US MAKE EVERY MOMENT COUNCIL
THAT WHETHER WE HAVE ONE TERM OR
SIX TERMS.
THE PEOPLE OF THIS GREAT STATE
WILL REMEMBER WHAT WE DID.
AND NOT MERELY SAY. OH MY GOD.
SHE DID SIX TERMS.
AND THEN SHE LEFT.
THAT IS ALSO IN.
A THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER MAYES.
READY BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible]
IT'S A ZERO WHICH STANDS ONE
NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
FRIDAY DECEMBER FOURTEENTH 2018%
TO THE PROVISIONS OF JOINT ALL
THIRTY NINE THE FOLLOWING
ASSEMBLY JOURNAL FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY REGULAR SESSION
WAS PRINTED WALLACE SIMPLY WAS
AN ORGANIZATIONAL RECESS MISTER
CALDERON MOVES.
AND MR OBERNOLTE SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION A REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES FOR PERSONAL
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARIE
WALDRON.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION SIR THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO ALLOW
SOMEONE MEMBERS BERMAN AND
MULLIN TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
SOMETHING MEMBERS GLORIA.
MELENDEZ QUIRK SILVA AND WOOD TO
SPEAK ON IN TERM IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GAS IN
THE ASSEMBLY TODAY IF I COULD
HAVE YOUR ATTENTION MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
MISTER BERMAN ADDRESSING THE
ASSEMBLY FROM MY DESK IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER MISTER
BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES IT IS MY HONOR TO
INTRODUCE DOCTOR CLAIBORNE
CARSON.
AN ACTIVIST HISTORIAN AND
FOUNDING DIRECTOR OF THE MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR RESEARCH AND
EDUCATION INSTITUTE AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY.
DR CARSON HAS DEVOTED MOST OF
HIS PROFESSIONAL LIFE TO THE
STUDY OF MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR AND THE MOVEMENTS KING
INSPIRED.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE DR
CARSON WAS SELECTED BY MRS
CORETTA SCOTT KING. TO EDIT AND
PUBLISH THE PAPERS OF HER LATE
HUSBAND DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR CREATING WHAT IS NOW
KNOWN AS THE KING PAPERS PROJECT.
UNDER DR CARSON'S DIRECTION THE
KING PAPERS PROJECT IS PRODUCED
SEVEN VOLUMES OF THE PAPERS OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE HE FOUNDED
THE MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION INSTITUTE
AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
THEINSTITUTE WORKS TO PROVIDE A
PERMANENT FINANCIAL BASE FOR THE
KING PAPERS PROJECT INTO
CULTIVATE UNDERSTANDING OF KINGS
INSPIRING LEGACY IN THE
CLASSROOM AND BEYOND.
IN ADDITION TO HIS YEARS OF
TEACHING AT STANFORD DR CARSON
IS TAUGHT AT UCLA THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA BERKELEY.
AMERICAN UNIVERSITY EMORY
UNIVERSITY AT MOREHOUSE COLLEGE
IN A SCHOOL IN PARIS --
AND THE SENATE IS HOSTING A
RECEPTION IN ROOM TWO ELEVEN
AFTER THEIR SESSION FOR DR
CARSON --
PLEASE JOIN ME AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN IN WELCOMING
DOCTOR CLAYBORNE CARSON TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
WE ARE THIRD READING.
FILE ITEMS ONE TWO AND THREE
PASS AND RETAIN.
I WAS WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR THIS IS ON THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE.
HOUSE RESOLUTION NUMBER SIX BY
RAMON CORPORATE.
HOUSE RESOLUTION SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIMO AND RELATIVE TO
WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH.
MS Là MON ON THE RESOLUTION
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND TO MEMBERS.
TODAY I BRING BEFORE YOU HR SIX
COMMEMORATING THE FORTY SIXTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT DECISION.
IN ROE VERSUS WADE.
THIS CASE AFFIRMED EVERY WOMAN
HAS THE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO
CONTROL HER OWN.
REPRODUCTIVE DECISIONS AND
WHETHER TO CONTINUE A PREGNANCY
OR OBTAIN A LEGAL ABORTION.
THE ROLE THE WAY DECISION
REMAINS THE CORNERSTONE OF A
PERSON'S ABILITY TO CONTROL
THEIR OWN REPRODUCTIVE LIVES.
ROE V. WADE WAS A VICTORY FOR
WOMEN TO THEIR OWN BODIES.
AND LAID THE GROUNDWORK FOR
FURTHER REPRODUCTIVE AND SEXUAL
HEALTH CARE POLICIES THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY [inaudible]
IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE ONE OF TWO
STATES WHERE THE RIGHT IS
PROTECTED IN BOTH STATUTE AND
OUR CONSTITUTION.
HOUSE RESOLUTION SIX SOLIDIFIES
THE ASSEMBLY SUPPORT AND
COMMITMENT TO PROTECT A PERSON'S
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO DECIDE IF.
AND WHEN THEY BECOME APPARENT.
EVEN WITH THESE PROTECTIONS THE
RIGHT TO ACCESS ABORTION STEEPLY
AND LEGALLY IN THIS COUNTRY IS
IN JEOPARDY.
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
SUPREME COURT CAN STILL NARROW
THESE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT.
THE PROTECTIONS GRANTED BY ROE
V. WADE.
ARE THE HIGHEST RISK OF BEING
OVERTURNED.
ACCORDING TO NATIONAL STUDY
[inaudible]
AMERICANS OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORT
ROE VERSUS WADE DECISIONS WITH
72% OF AMERICANS SUPPORTING
ACCESS TO LEGAL ABORTION.
IT IS VITAL FOR CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS HOME TO NEARLY TWENTY MILLION
WOMEN. TO RECOGNIZE AND
CELEBRATE THESE FUNDAMENTAL.
ESPECIALLY DURING A TIME WHEN
PROVIDERS OF REPRODUCTIVE AND
SEXUAL HEALTH CARE ARE UNDER
SERIOUS UNRELENTING.
ATTACKS TO PROVIDE A SAFE AND
LEGAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE A STORY
WITH YOU.
FROM A CONSTITUENT OF MINE.
HER MOTHER FIRST BROUGHT HER TO
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFTER
LEARNING SHE WAS SEXUALLY ACTIVE.
ALTHOUGH THE FAMILY COULDN'T
AFFORD HEALTH INSURANCE HER
MOTHER KNEW HOW IMPORTANT
RECEIVING INFORMATIVE HOLISTIC
REPRODUCTIVE CARE WAS.
A FEW YOU'RE LATE FEW YEARS
LATER THAT SAME MOTHER.
FOUND HERSELF IN THE SHOES OF
HER DAUGHTER.
AT ONE POINT SHE TOOK HER
DAUGHTER TO PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AND NOW SHE WAS GOING TO PLANNED
PARENTHOOD TO RECEIVE HOLISTIC
INFORMATION.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT MOTHER WAS
UNABLE TO CARRY THE BABY TO TERM
DUE TO HEALTH ISSUES.
THE ABORTION WAS NOT COVERED BY
HER INSURANCE.
THIS STORY IS NOT UNIQUE
REAFFIRMS OUR BELIEF THAT
HOLISTIC REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE IS AN INVALUABLE RESOURCE
TO OUR COMMUNITY.
MEMBERS.
I LIKE MANY OF YOU STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF WOMEN'S
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT ASK CONFIRMED
BY ROE V. WADE [inaudible] TO
MAKE.
OUR OWN DECISIONS REGARDING OUR
PREGNANCY AN URGENT AN AYE VOTE
ON H. R..
SIX THANK YOU MS LAMONT IS WICKS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY ON THE FORTY SIXTH
ANNIVERSARY OF ROE V. WADE. TO
ASK MY COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT HR
SIX A RESOLUTION AFFIRMING THE
RIGHT OF AMERICAN WOMEN ACCESS
ABORTION.
AND I RISE TODAY FOR MY FIRST
TIME AS AN ASSEMBLY WOMAN TO
SHARE MY OWN STORY. TO TALK
ABOUT MY OWN ABORTION.
BECAUSE MY STORY IS ALSO THE
STORY OF MILLIONS OF OTHER
AMERICAN WOMEN.
THE STORY WOMEN WHO CAN'T SPEAK
OUT WHO CAN'T RISE TO THIS
MICROPHONE.
WOMEN WHO UNJUSTLY FACE BULLYING
AND SHAME.
WOMEN WHO UNJUSTLY STRUGGLE THE
EVEN ACCESS ABORTION SERVICES IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
I HAD AN ABORTION.
I WAS TWENTY SIX YEARS OLD.
IN BETWEEN JOBS AND IN BETWEEN
HOMES.
I HAD NO HEALTH INSURANCE.
STAYING AT A FRIEND'S COUCH
UNEMPLOYED.
AND FACING AN UNPLANNED
PREGNANCY WAS A VULNERABLE TIME
IN MY LIFE.
IN THIS MOMENT.
I TURNED TO PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
I WILL NEVER FORGET WALKING INTO
THAT CLINIC IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THE END EASE I FELT WAS MET WITH
ACCEPTANCE AND COMPASSION BY THE
STAFF.
AFTER A POSITIVE PREGNANCY TEST
IN A THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION
ABOUT MY OPTIONS.
I DECIDED ABORTION WAS THE RIGHT
DECISION FOR ME.
ACCESS TO ABORTION IS OFTEN
DEBATED IN OUR POLITICS IN THE
ABSTRACT.
BUT BEING ABLE TO CHOOSE WHEN
AND WHEN NOT TO HAVE CHILDREN IS
FOR MANY WOMEN AS IT WAS FOR ME
AN EXTREMELY PERSONAL.
AND PRACTICAL CONSIDERATION. FOR
ME HAVING AN ABORTION WAS AN
EMPOWERING DECISION. ONE THAT I
HAVE NEVER REGRETTED.
IT WAS NOT YET MY TIME TO HAVE
CHILDREN. FOR MANY WOMEN THIS
DECISION COMES WITH
HEARTBREAKING STRUGGLE. FOR MANY
WOMEN A DIFFERENT DECISION IS
MADE.
BUT ULTIMATELY IT IS OUR
DECISION TO MAKE. FIFTEEN YEARS
LATER.
I AM AN ASSEMBLY WOMAN A WIFE
AND THE MOTHER OF A TWO YEAR OLD
GIRL NAMED JOSEPHINE.
WE CALL HER JO JO AND SHE IS MY
HEART.
SINCE MY ABORTION I WORKED FOR
PRESIDENT OBAMA FOR SIX YEARS
INCLUDING IN HIS WHITE HOUSE AS
PART OF THE TEAM THAT HELPED
PASS THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
I LAUNCH THE NATIONAL WOMEN'S
INITIATIVE AIMED AT GETTING
BETTER PAID LEAVE POLICIES IN
MORE AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE.
I RUN A STATEWIDE PARENT
ORGANIZING PROGRAM TO GET MORE
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
I'VE HELPED TO LIKE STRONG WOMEN
LEADERS TO OFFICE.
WHEN THEY LOOK AT HOW MY LIFE
HAS UNFOLDED IN THESE FIFTEEN
YEARS I AM ALL THE MORE JUST
MORE CERTAIN ABOUT MY DECISION?
IT DOES ALLOW ME TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HAVE CHILDREN WHEN
I'M READY.
THE ABILITY TO ACCESS SAFE
ABORTIONS UNDER THREAT.
EVERY DAY IN THIS COUNTRY THERE
ARE PEOPLE WORKING TO UNDERMINE
ROE V. WADE TO RESTRICT A
WOMAN'S ACCESS TO ABORTION.
EVERY DAY THERE ARE LEGISLATORS
TRYING TO PASS ANTI ABORTION
BILLS.
LIKE THE FOUR HUNDRED PLUS ANTI
ABORTION LAWS ENACTED AT THE
STATE LEVEL IN THE LAST DECADE.
EVERY DAY DONALD TRUMP IS
WORKING TO CONFIRM JUDGES WHO
WOULD OVER TORN OR HOLLOW OUT
OUR ABORTION RIGHTS.
THAT'S WHY IN THIS STATE IN THIS
CHAMBER WE FIGHT EVERY DAY NOT
ONLY TO A HOLD ROVI WEIGHED BUT
TO EXPAND ABORTION ACCESS TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO BIRTH CONTROL.
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO PREVENTIVE
HEALTH CARE TO STAND UP FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND TO TO
STIGMATIZE ABORTION.
A PROCEDURE THAT ONE QUARTER OF
AMERICAN WOMEN WILL HAVE IN
THEIR LIFETIMES.
I'M PROUD TO SHARE MY STORY WITH
YOU TODAY AND I ASKED YOU STAND
WITH ME AND SUPPORT HR.
SIX THANK YOU MISS WICKS.
THIS METHOD WITH.
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY AS A WOMAN
WHO HAS SURVIVED TO HIGH RISK
PREGNANCIES TO DELIVER TWO
BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTERS WHOSE
FREEDOMS AND WHOSE FUTURES ARE
PRECIOUS TO ME.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR SIX TO
COMMEMORATE THE FORTY SIXTH
ANNIVERSARY OF ROE VERSUS WADE.
IN THE FORTY SIX YEARS SINCE ROE
WAS DECIDED THOUSANDS OF
AMERICAN WOMEN'S LIVES HAVE BEEN
SAVED BY ACCESS TO LEGAL
ABORTION CARE.
WOMEN HAVE A RIGHT TO CHOOSE THE
PATH OF OUR OWN LIVES.
AS I HAVE PERSONALLY FOUND A
WOMAN'S LIFE LIBERTY HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC WELL BEING ARE
UNDENIABLY TIED TO HER
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM.
WOMEN HAVE A RIGHT TO END
PREGNANCIES IN A SAFE AND TIMELY
MANNER.
WE DESERVE THE RIGHT TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE CARE WE NEED AN
ACCESS IT WITH DIGNITY.
TODAY ABORTION IS ONE OF THE
SAFEST MEDICAL PROCEDURES
AVAILABLE. 43% OF CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES HOWEVER DO NOT HAVE
ADEQUATE ABORTION CARE.
MEANING THE APPROXIMATELY ONE
MILLION WOMEN WHO LIVE IN THESE
COUNTIES MUST FACE AN ADDITIONAL
BURDEN TO OBTAIN THE CARE THEY
NEED.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
LEADER ON ACCESS BUT EVEN ON QUE
IN CALIFORNIA WE CAN AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO BETTER WE MUST.
TODAY IS A DAY TO CELEBRATE HOW
FAR WE'VE COME IN CALIFORNIA TO
EXPAND AND PROTECT REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM FOR ALL.
BUT IT IS ALSO A DAY TO RECOMMIT
OURSELVES TO CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
ACCESS AND EQUALITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON HR.
SIX MS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA BLACK
CAUCUS. TO SUPPORT H. R. SIX TO
MARK THE FORTY SIXTH ANNIVERSARY
OF ROE V. WADE.
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE
ABORTION HAS BECOME ONE OF THE
SAFEST MEDICAL PROCEDURES IN THE
UNITED STATES WITH THE SAFETY
RECORD OF OVER 99%.
ROE V. WADE ALLOWS WOMEN TO
CONTROL THEIR REPRODUCTIVE LIVES.
PROTECTING OUR HEALTH AND
FREEDOM [inaudible]
AS WOMEN.
WE HAVE BEEN DENIED THE RIGHT TO
VOTE.
DENIED THE RIGHT TO WORK.
AND DENIED THE RIGHT TO CONTROL
OUR BODIES.
AND WE HAVE SUCCESSFULLY FOUGHT
AGAINST THOSE PREJUDICES.
YET THESE FIGHTS CONTINUE TO
WAGE.
IN MICRO AND IN MACRO WAYS.
BECAUSE FOR SOME REASON.
A WOMAN KNOWING WHAT IS BEST FOR
HERSELF.
REMAINS IN QUESTION.
ACCESS IS TRULY ON THE LINE.
WITH SEVERAL CASES JUST ONE STEP
AWAY FROM THE SUPREME COURT
NARROWING ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH SERVICE.
THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
AND THE STAFF SUPREME COURT ARE
THREATENING THE FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS OF MORE THAN ONE THIRD OF
THE WOMEN IN THIS COUNTRY.
WHEN HEALTH CARE IS ATTACKED?
THE POLICIES DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT PEOPLE OF COLOR WOMEN THE
LGBT COMMUNITY AND YOUNG PEOPLE.
WE MUST WORK TO ENSURE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE THAT DOES NOT DEPEND
ON WHO YOU ARE WHERE YOU LIVE OR
HOW MUCH MONEY YOU MAKE. 82% OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT ACCESS TO A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT PLANNED PARENTHOOD
WHICH PROVIDES A VARIETY OF
HEALTH SERVICES TO OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA.
OPPONENTS OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
WILL TELL YOU THAT TAXPAYERS ARE
FUNDING ABORTIONS BUT I CAN TELL
YOU THAT IS NOT TRUE LAST YEAR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD PROVIDED. ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
CANCER SCREENINGS AND
ADMINISTERED ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION S. T. I. TESTS.
THOSE TESTS ALONE.
SAVE THOUSANDS OF LIVES.
THESE ARE OUR BODIES.
AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
DECIDE WHAT IS BEST FOR US.
CALIFORNIA MUST CONTINUE LEADING
THE FIGHT FOR REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE.
AND HR SIX INSURES THAT WOMEN
HAVE THE FULL PROTECTIONS THAT
WERE GUARANTEED UNDER ROE V.
WADE.
SO AS A WALK WOMAN AND AS A
PROUD MEMBER OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD LOS ANGELES.
I THINK WE'VE TIRED THANK YOU
AND RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON HR.
SIX THERE WAS KAMLAGER-DOVE MISS
KOREA [inaudible]
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF HR SIX TO COMMEMORATE
THE LANDMARK US SUPREME COURT
DECISION.
THAT ENSURES A PERSON'S
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT. TO A SAFE
AND LEGAL ABORTION.
AS ONE OF THE FIRST STATES IN
OUR COUNTRY TO LEGALIZE ABORTION.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE EMPOWERED WITH
THE ABILITY TO CONTROL THEIR OWN
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
DECISIONS.
WELL TODAY WE COMMEMORATE THE
PROGRESS WE HAVE ACHIEVED.
SINCE THIS GROUNDBREAKING
DECISION.
WE MUST RECOGNIZE THAT ACCESS TO
ABORTION CONTINUES TWO VERY
DRASTICALLY DEPENDING ON ONE'S
RACIAL ETHNIC AND SOCIAL
ECONOMIC BACKGROUND.
IT IS CRITICAL.
NOW MORE THAN EVER THAT WE
CONTINUE TO PROTECT THE FREEDOM
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS TO CHOOSE
WHEN AND HOW.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO START A
FAMILY.
IN JANUARY OF LAST YEAR.
THE SPEAKER ORGANIZED A
DELEGATION TO ALL SALVADOR.
MY COUNTRY OF BIRTH.
WHEN ASKED WHAT WHERE SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE SHOULD
ADDRESS?
I IMMEDIATELY SAID.
WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
WOMEN'S WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS.
AND IT WAS CHALLENGED BECAUSE AS
A PROUD TO ANOTHER ANYA.
AS A PROUD WOMAN WOMAN OF COLOR
AND NOW IS A PROUD MEMBER OF
THIS BODY.
HOW DO YOU GO TO YOUR HOME
COUNTRY AND SAY WHAT YOU ARE
DOING TO WOMEN'S RIGHTS IS
IMMORAL?
YOU SEE THE COUNTRY ABLE
SALVADOR'S INCARCERATING WOMEN
FOR SIMPLY HAVING A MISCARRIAGE.
SOMETHING THAT IS A NATURAL AND
PAINFUL EXPERIENCE TO A WOMAN.
AND WE HAD THOSE HARD AND TOUGH
CONVERSATIONS.
AND WHEN YOU QUESTION WHAT WHAT
IS THE ROLE OF A STATE.
WHAT IS THE ROLE OF AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND HAVING A STATE TO
COUNTRY CONVERSATION?
THAT IS THE POWER OF WHAT WE DO.
WE HAVE A PERSONAL CONNECTION TO
THE ISSUE.
WE ARE ABLE TO ADVOCATE FOR
WOMEN.
FAMILIES AND I AM THANKFUL TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN OUR COLLEAGUES
THAT WERE ON THAT DELEGATION
WITH ME IN.
AND TO THE SPEAKER WHO ALLOWED
FOR THAT CONVERSATION TO TAKE
PLACE.
BECAUSE THESE CONVERSATIONS ARE
NOT EASY.
AND WE FIND OURSELVES NOW IN A
TIME IN OUR OWN COUNTRY.
WHERE WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH AND OUR CHOICES ARE
QUESTION?
AND SO TODAY AND ALWAYS WHETHER
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ACROSS OUR NATION OR ANYWHERE IN
THE WORLD.
WE MUST STAND UNITED. FOR WHAT
IS RIGHT FOR WHAT IS JUST. FOR A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO MAKE A DECISION.
OVER HER OWN BODY.
SO I STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR HR SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS KOREA.
IS PETRIE-NORRIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I ALSO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
H. R..
SIX RIGHT NOW AT THIS MOMENT
FORTY SIX YEARS AFTER THE
PASSAGE AND THE CERTIFICATION OF
ROE V. WADE AS THE LAW OF THE
LAND.
OUR SUPPORT IS MORE IMPORTANT
MORE URGENT AND MORE CRITICAL
THAN EVER.
BECAUSE THE SIMPLE TRUTH IS THAT
WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS ARE
UNDER ATTACK.
IS NOTED BY MY COLLEAGUE
REPRESENTING SANTA BARBARA
AMERICANS OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORT
THE RIGHTS PROTECTED BY ROE V.
WADE.
THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY THE RIGHT
TO REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM.
INCLUDING SAFE AND LEGAL
ABORTION CARE.
BUT DESPITE THE SUPPORT RUBY
WAIT IS NEVER BEEN MORE AT RISK
THAN IT IS TODAY.
THERE ARE AT LEAST TWENTY CASES
THAT COULD SIGNIFICANTLY GOT
PROTECTIONS OF ROW.
AND WITH TWO OF TRUMP'S ANTI
CHOICE APPOINTEES NOW ON THE
SUPREME COURT THE THREAT OF
OVERTURNING ROE.
OF CRIMINALIZING ABORTION.
AND OF PUNISHING WOMEN IS REAL
AND IMMEDIATE.
THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION HAS
REINSTATED THE GLOBAL GAG CRAWL.
PROPOSED A DOMESTIC GAG RULE
ENABLED EMPLOYERS TO DENY
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR BIRTH
CONTROL FOR VIRTUALLY ANY REASON.
THE ONSLAUGHT OF FEDERAL ATTACKS
AND WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS
IS UNRELENTING.
THE CALIFORNIA AS IN SO MANY
WAYS WILL CONTINUE TO LEAD THE
RESISTANCE WE WILL CONTINUE TO
FIGHT BACK AGAINST THE MISOGYNY
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS ABOUT A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE THIS IS ABOUT A WOMAN'S
RIGHT TO ACCESS AND IS SO MANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID.
THIS IS ABOUT A WOMEN'S RIGHT TO
MAKE CHOICES ABOUT HER OWN BODY.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
URGE AN AYE VOTE ON HR
.
SIX BAUER-KAHAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED [inaudible]
DRAFT.
TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR
SIX AS A WOMAN.
A MOTHER AND A MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION.
ROE V. WADE RECOGNIZED WOMAN'S
RIGHT WOMEN'S RIGHT TO PRIVACY
OVER THEIR OWN BODIES.
ROW ISN'T JUST A SUPREME COURT
CASE.
IF THE PROMISE THAT EVERY WOMAN
HAS THE POWER AND DIGNITY. TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT HER OWN
LIFE.
BODY AND FUTURE.
THE WOMAN WHO IS KERRY CHILDREN.
I KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF MAKING
THAT DECISION ONESELF.
AND IS THE GREAT SENATOR FROM
CALIFORNIA SENATOR HARRIS
POINTED OUT IN THE RECENT
HEARINGS OF JUDGE CABIN ON THERE
ARE NO LAWS THAT IMPINGE ON THE
RIGHT OF PRIVACY FOR MEN.
BY STRIKING DOWN CRIMINAL
ABORTION LAWS ROW CREATED THE
PROMISE THAT ANYONE WHO DECIDES
TO END A PREGNANCY IS ABLE TO DO
SO SLEEVE SAFELY.
WITH DIGNITY AND FREE FROM
ARREST.
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN EXPANDING AND
PROTECTING THE RIGHT TO AN
ABORTION.
THROUGH ARE STATE CONSTITUTION
AND THROUGH THE REPRODUCTIVE
PRIVACY ACT [inaudible]
AND YET.
THE REALITY OF ROW AROUND THE
COUNTRY IS THE ANTI CHOICE
EXTREMISTS.
HAD BEEN WORKING FOR THE LAST
FORTY YEARS TO CHIP AWAY AT
WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS.
THROUGH OUR COURTS ARE STATE
HOUSES.
AND NOW THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND THROUGHOUT THE NATION
CRIMINALIZATION OF ABORTION IS
ON THE RISE. TWELVE STATES HAVE
A PRE ROLL BAND AND OR A TRIGGER
BAN IT WOULD IMMEDIATELY
CRIMINALIZE ABORTION IF ROE IS
OVERTURNED.
ANOTHER SEVEN STATES HAVE
EXPRESSED AN INTENT TO RESTRICT
THE RIGHT TO ABORTION IF ROE IS
OVERTURNED.
SINCE TWENTY TEN STATE
LEGISLATURES HAVE PASSED SOME
FOUR HUNDRED ANTI CHOICE BILLS.
AS THE NEW YORK TIMES RECENT
EDITORIAL A WOMEN'S RIGHTS
CAUTIONED US MORE AND MORE LAWS
ARE TREATING A FETUS IS A PERSON.
AND A WOMAN AS LESS OF ONE AS
STATES CHARGE PREGNANT WOMEN
WITH CRIMES.
BOTH PARTIES USED TO AGREE THAT
ABORTION IS A PRIVATE MATTER.
BUT IN THE LAST FEW DECADES FAR
RIGHT EXTREMISTS HAVE EMBRACED A
FETAL RIGHTS.
INTENTIONALLY DESIGNED TO
UNDERMINE ROE AND DIMINISH THE
RIGHTS OF PREGNANT WOMEN.
THE PUBLIC DOES NOT SUPPORT THE
CONCEPT OF PERSONHOOD.
IN MISSISSIPPI VOTERS REJECTED
PERSONHOOD BALLOT MEASURE BY
SIXTEEN POINTS.
NORTH DAKOTA REJECTED A SIMILAR
MEASURE BY TWENTY NINE POINT.
IN COLORADO VOTERS REJECTED ANY
ANTI CHOICE PERSONHOOD BALLOT.
BY A THREE TO ONE MARGIN.
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT WHEN LIFE
BEGINS BELONGS WITH OUR
SCIENTISTS.
OUR CLERGY AND AMERICAN FAMILIES.
IN FACT IN JUDAISM.
LIFE BEGINS AT BIRTH.
NOT A CONCEPTION.
THIS IS A PRIVATE DECISION THE
EACH OF US MUST MAKE IN PRIVATE
CONSULTATION WITH OUR OWN
TRUSTED SOURCES.
THIS CONVERSATION DOES NOT
BELONG IN A POLITICAL AGENDA.
THAT ARE ROADS THE EXISTING
RIGHTS OF A PARTICULAR CLASS
[inaudible]
WOMEN.
IN FACT WE KNOWS THE CONTROL OF
ONE'S OWN REPRODUCTIVE FUTURE IS
THE GREATEST EQUALIZER OF WOMEN
IN THE WORKFORCE.
IN CALIFORNIA WE PRIDE OURSELVES
ON LEADING THE NATION AND WE DO.
BUT WE'RE NOT IMMUNE.
AS THE WAR AGAINST WOMEN'S
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS WAGES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY WE MUST CONTINUE TO
LEAD.
IN CALIFORNIA MY WE MUST
RECOMMIT TO GUARANTEEING THAT
ANYONE WHO DECIDES TO ACCESS
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO AN
ABORTION.
IS ABLE TO DO SO SAFELY.
EFFECTIVELY.
WITH THE DIGNITY.
AND FREE FROM ARREST.
WOMEN HAVE A RIGHT TO PRIVACY
OVER THEIR OWN BODIES.
AS GUARANTEED IN ROW.
AND SHOULD BE MAKING THEIR
REPRODUCTION OF DECISIONS
WITHOUT GOVERNMENTAL
INTERFERENCE.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE
ON HR SIX THANK YOU.
MR COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I JUST TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE A LITTLE
BIT PERSONALLY FROM.
THE COOLEY FAMILY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. FOR THE
CURIOSITIES OF MY LIFE BOTH MY
PARENTS GREW UP IS SINGLE HAVING
NO MOM AND HOME.
A MY MOM AT AGE.
EIGHT IN NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT
FOSTER MOM WHO WENT.
WHEN OFF TO GET AN ABORTION?
IT WASN'T SAFE [inaudible]
IT WASN'T.
USERS OF A BACK ALLEY SORT OF
THING.
SO MY MOM GREW UP WITH THIS
INCREDIBLE HOLE IN HER HEART.
HAVING LOST HER MOM.
SHE LIVED IN OKLAHOMA.
FROM AJ TO SORT OF PASSED AROUND
OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS AS THE
GREAT DEPRESSION BEFELL OUR
COUNTRY [inaudible]
AND MY DAD ALSO LOST HIS MOM BUT
HE LOST HIS MOM IN CHILDBIRTH IS
A MARVEL TO ME.
THAT THESE TWO PEOPLE WHO GREW
UP BOTH WITH A BIG HOLE IN THEIR
HEART.
FROM THE LOSS OF A MOM.
MANAGE TO FIND EACH OTHER AND
FALL IN LOVE IN OFFER
CONSOLATION EACH OTHER BUT I
JUST KNOW.
THE HURT THAT REPRESENTED SO I
RISE IN.
SUPPORT OF THIS THIS IDEA.
THAT IT IS AVAILABLE IT IS SAFE.
IT IS A VERY CONSEQUENTIAL
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
VERY VERY MEANINGFUL FOR THOSE
FOR WHOM ARE CAUGHT UP IN IT.
AND IT STAVES OFF THIS TRAGEDY
THAT BEFELL MY MOM IS A IS A
LITTLE GIRL.
AS HER MOM IS THERE ONE DAY AND
THEN IS NOT THERE.
AND HER WHOLE LIFE TOOK A
DIFFERENT TURN --
SO I'M.
HONORED RICE'S SUPPORTERS.
THANK YOU WAS COOLEY MS MELENDEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS -- I
I FIRST WANT TO SAY THAT.
I AM FULLY AWARE THAT ANY
COMMENTS THAT I MAKE TO ISN'T
GOING TO CHANGE ANYONE'S MIND
HERE AND THAT'S NOT WHY STAND --
AND TYPICALLY I DON'T STAND UP
AND SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE THAT WE
VOTE ON EVERY YEAR.
UP BY THIS YEAR.
I JUST I FEEL COMPELLED TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF THOSE WHO HAVE NO
VOICE IN THESE CHAMBERS EVERY
YEAR WE VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION
AND I RESPECT THE FACT.
THAT SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES SEE
THIS DIFFERENTLY THAN I DO I'M
I'M OKAY WITH THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TO AGREE ON EVERYTHING --
BUT THE ONE THING THAT HAS
ALWAYS BOTHERED ME IS THAT THIS
RESOLUTION IS BROUGHT UP AND
THERE IS MUCH DISCUSSION.
ABOUT THE RIGHTS OF WOMEN TO
CONTROL THEIR BODIES THE RIGHTS
OF WOMEN TO HAVE CONTROL OF
THEIR OWN REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH.
YET THERE IS NEVER ANY
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE RIGHTS OF
THE GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE YET.
BEEN GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TAKE THEIR AND I'VE NEVER
UNDERSTOOD WHY THAT IS.
WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME TALKING
IN THESE CHAMBERS ABOUT
PROTECTING.
A AND KEEPING SAFE CHILDREN.
MINORITIES WOMEN LGBT COMMUNITY
EVERYBODY UNDER THE SUN EXCEPT.
FOR THE UNBORN.
THEY HAVE NO VOICE.
AND TO THOSE SITTING IN THE IN
THE GALLERY IT MIGHT APPEAR THAT
THEY HAVE NO ADVOCATES HERE.
BUT THEY DO.
THERE ARE FEWER OF US BUT THEY
DO SO I AM RISING ON BEHALF OF
THE UNBORN.
I'M RISING AS THE MOTHER OF FIVE
HE WASBLESSED TO BE ABLE TO
BRING.
FIVE LIVES INTO THIS WORLD.
I DON'T JUDGE OTHERS WHO MADE A
DIFFERENT DECISION.
BUT I ASK THAT WE RESPECT ONE
ANOTHER.
THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE.
THAT THERE ARE THOSE OF US WHO.
WHO BELIEVE IN THE SANCTITY OF
LIFE?
WHETHER YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO TAKE
YOUR FIRST RECORD NOT.
I JUST ASK THAT YOU RECOGNIZE
THAT.
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO DROWN OUT
THE VOICES.
WITH THE ROARING CROWD OF SAYING
THAT ROE V. WADE IS IN JEOPARDY
OR THAT I BECAUSE I'M I'M I'M A
PRO LIFE.
PERSON THAT I SOMEHOW DON'T
BELIEVE IN WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
THAT'S AN AFFRONT TO ALL OF US
THAT DO.
AND THE TWO CAN COEXIST.
SO WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE.
MR GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE LGBT CAUCUS
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT HOUSE
RESOLUTION SIX COMMEMORATING THE
FORTY SIXTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
LANDMARK DECISION OF ROE V. WADE.
AS A CAUCUS WE KNOW VERY WELL
THAT THE JOURNEY TO A QUALITY IS
A VERY DIFFICULT.
ONE MARRIAGE EQUALITY WORKPLACE
EQUALITY IMMIGRATION OF QUALITY
AND EVEN TODAY DIVIDE IN ABILITY
TO SERVE AREN'T IN OUR NATION'S.
ARMED FORCES.
BUT NOTHING.
NOTHING CAN COMPARE TO
DESTRUCTION RUGGLES THAT WOMEN
FACE AND CONTINUE TO FACE. TO
SIR THEIR EQUALITY UNDER THE LAW
AND OF COURSE TAKE.
CONTROL OF THEIR OWN HEALTH CARE.
THIS IS MENTIONED AT A RECENT
JUDICIAL CONFIRMATION HEARING
OUR STATE OUR SENATOR COMMA
HARRIS ASKED.
CAN YOU THINK OF ANY LAWS THAT
GIVE GOVERNMENT THE POWER TO
MAKE DECISIONS.
ABOUT THE MALE BODY.
THE NOMINEES RESPONSE.
I'M NOT THINKING OF ANY RIGHT
NOW.
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY.
AS A MAN.
INCAPABLE OF DONATING BLOOD.
BUT FULLY CAPABLE OF EXERCISING
MY OWN DISCRETION OVER MY OWN
BODY.
AND THAT RIGHT IS UNQUESTIONED
AND UNCHALLENGED.
BECAUSE I'M A MAN.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE
SAFEGUARD THE CAPABILITY.
THERE WILL BE WEIGHED GIVES TO
WOMEN TO DO THE VERY SAME THING.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR LGBT
COMMUNITY.
A PRICKLY THOSE OUR COMMUNITY
WHO ARE ABLE TO CONCEIVE.
RESEARCH HAS IDENTIFIED.
HIGHER SEXUAL RATES OF PREGNANCY
YOU KNOW GP KEY YOU.
AS COMPARED TO THE HETEROSEXUAL
PEERS.
SPICE SURPRISINGLY SEMI.
AND WHILE WILL BE WEIGHED MAY
HAVE ONLY ENTERTAINED OR THOUGHT
ABOUT CIS GENDERED WOMEN --
WHEN IT WAS?
RULED FIFTY A NEARLY FIFTY YEARS
AGO.
THIS DECISION SET A PRECEDENT
THAT HELPED ESTABLISH THE RIGHTS
OF OUR TRANS GENDER.
MEMBERS OF OUR BELOVED LGBT Q.
COMMUNITY.
SO ARE CAUCUS STANDS HERE.
COMMITTED TO MAKING PAINTING
THIS AS THE LAW OF OUR LAND NOT
JUST TODAY ON THIS ANNIVERSARY
BUT ON EVERY DAY WE MUST AFFIRM
OUR COMMITMENT OF NEVER SLIDING
BACKWARD.
INTO THE DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES OF DICTATING HOW
OTHERS MADE WHAT MADE YOU TAKE
CARE OF THEIR BODIES.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK RISK FOR BREAST COOPER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I SEE AN PLAN ON SPEAKING BUT I
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR --
SIX MOMS TO BE EIGHTY TWO THIS
YEAR AND SHE WAS NINE YEARS OLD
HER MOM WAS THE WIDOW OF SEVEN
CHILDREN.
AND GOT PREGNANT.
WITH SEVEN KIDS LIVING BY
HERSELF.
AND SHE TO GO GET A BACK ALLEY
ABORTION LIKE MR AMISH MY
COLLEAGUE RICH CLOVER --
SHE DIED FROM THAT WHEN I WAS
NINE YEARS OLD THINK SISTER WAS
ELEVEN YEARS OLD THEY'RE IN
THERE WITH THEIR MOTHER.
COVERING THEIR MOTHER WHEN SHE
DIES THAT THAT'S CRAZY THIS DAY
IN AGE AND I DO THINK WOMEN'S
RIGHTS ARE BEING INFRINGED UPON --
I'VE GOT FOUR DAUGHTERS AND A
MALE WHO MY TO MY DAUGHTER'S
WHAT TO DO OR ANYONE.
IS NOT MY BODY.
SO I I RISE IN SUPPORT THIS ONE
THING MY COLLECTION OAKLAND FOR
STANDING UP ANOTHER COURAGE --
TO TO YOUR STORY WITH US IT'S
VERY POWERFUL VERY IMPACTFUL BUT
THINK ABOUT THIS FOR THREE
STORIES YOUR RECOGNIZE.
EGGMAN SPEAKER MEMBERS.
MY COMMENTS IN NO WAY.
SHOULD BE CONSTRUED [inaudible]
AS JUDGMENTAL.
BUT I NEED TO RISE AND TELL THE
STORY.
OF THE BLESSING OF A DIFFERENT.
KIND OF CHOICE.
I RISEN HERE BEFORE TO TALK
ABOUT MY ADOPTED.
SON BJ FROM VIETNAM.
I HAVE NOT SPOKEN OF MY MIDDLE
SON.
AND MY DAUGHTER.
THEY ARE ADOPTED AS WELL.
JASON WAS CONCEIVED BY A SIXTEEN
YEAR OLD.
OBVIOUSLY A PREGNANCY WITH
[inaudible]
GREAT DIFFICULTY.
AND THROUGH A CHOICE OF ANOTHER
KIND.
SHE DETERMINED TO BIRTH THAT
CHILD AND ABOUT EIGHT WEEKS
LATER.
WE WERE ABLE TO WELCOME.
THAT LITTLE BOY INTO OUR FAMILY
AND WE NAMED HIM [inaudible]
JASON [inaudible]
OUR DAUGHTER [inaudible]
WAS.
BIRTH BY A THIRTY SEVEN YEAR OLD
WOMAN.
AGAIN I CERTAINLY A PREGNANCY
WITH [inaudible]
COMPLICATIONS OBVIOUSLY
[inaudible]
BUT AGAIN.
A CHOICE OF A DIFFERENT KIND WAS
MADE.
THE CHOICE OF A DIFFERENT KIND.
BROUGHT TO US.
LINDSEY.
AND I CAN.
REMEMBER.
BEING IN THE HOSPITAL ROOM AND
BY HER SIDE AS SHE HANDED LINSEY
TWO DAYS OLD [inaudible]
THE SHERIN.
THESE ARE THE BLESSINGS.
OF A DIFFERENT KIND OF CHOICE.
THE SIXTEEN YEAR OLD
[inaudible]
GREW UP [inaudible]
MERRY.
HAS LIVED DAY.
GOOD AND WONDERFUL AND
PRODUCTIVE LIFE LIVES IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA NEAR US.
THE THIRTY SEVEN YEAR OLD BIRTH
MOTHER.
MARRIED A WONDERFUL MAN AT
THIRTY EIGHT AND HAD.
A BABY DAUGHTER.
WE STAY IN TOUCH.
I WILL BE A RESPECTFUL AND QUIET
NO.
ONLY BECAUSE I THINK WE ARE
[inaudible]
INCOMPLETE [inaudible]
AND MISSING.
AT LEAST.
A REFERENTIAL [inaudible]
APPRECIATION.
OF WHAT SOME WOMEN [inaudible]
CHOOSE.
AND WHAT THAT MEANS [inaudible]
FOR LIFE.
WE LIVE WITH.
THE JOY.
OF THAT CHOICE.
AND AND THAT CHOICE HAS MEANT
[inaudible]
BIRTHDAYS [inaudible]
GRADUATIONS [inaudible]
ANNIVERSARIES [inaudible]
GRANDCHILDREN.
SO I WOULD HOPE.
IN THE DISCOURSE HERE.
AND IN THE VOTE.
THAT THERE WOULD AT LEAST BE A
RECOLLECTION.
AND A HEART FELT APPRECIATION.
FOUR CHOICE OF A DIFFERENT
[inaudible]
KIND.
AND I STAND HERE.
AS I SAID NOT IN JUDGMENT.
BUT S. A WITNESS. TO A DIFFERENT
DECISION.
AND THE JOY THAT THAT.
CAN CREATE.
WE WE DON'T CELEBRATE
[inaudible]
DON'T WRITE.
RESOLUTIONS WE DON'T.
BRING WOMEN HERE. TO ENCOURAGE
AND CELEBRATE [inaudible]
THAT [inaudible]
DECISION.
AND I I WOULD JUST.
BE REMISS IF I DID NOT STAND
DOWN VOICE.
WHAT'S IN OUR HEARTS.
AND INSURANCE HEART.
AND THAT THIS CHOICE OF A
DIFFERENT.
NATURE.
CAN BE ONE WITHOUT THE KIND OF
ABSOLUTE AN IRREVOCABLE.
DECISION [inaudible]
AND YET.
THAT IS A DECISION THAT CAN BE
MADE AND IS [inaudible]
LEGAL.
NOW I AM DOING IS.
RISING TO THANK TWO WONDERFUL.
WOMEN.
AND TO HONOR.
THE JOYFUL CONSEQUENCES.
OF THAT CHOICE [inaudible]
JASON [inaudible]
LINDSEY [inaudible]
LITTLE NOAH [inaudible]
JENNA [inaudible]
LESS THAN [inaudible]
ANJO V..
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES --
ON BOTH SIDES OF THIS ISSUE FOR
STANDING UP AND SHARING THEIR
ISSUE ARE THERE THEIR STORIES IN
THE PERSONAL EXPERIENCES WHEN IT
COMES -- TO
THE ISSUE THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHEN IT COMES TO WILL BE
WAIVED --
WHEN I MET MY WIFE WHAT WE
TALKED WE HAD A VERY SERIOUS
CONVERSATION --
WHEN WE FIRST STARTED DATING
ABOUT YOU KNOW IN THE EVENT?
THAT MY WIFE EVEN THOUGH SHE WAS
MY WIFE AT THE TIME IF YOU WERE
TO BECOME PREGNANT.
WHAT WOULD WE DO WHAT WHAT
WHAT'S THE DECISION OF WHETHER
WE'RE VERY EMPHATIC IN OUR
DECISION TO SAY THAT I SHOULD
HAVE DOES BECOME PREGNANT
ABORTION WAS NOT SOMETHING THAT
WE WERE GOING TO PURSUE WE WERE
GOING?
TO HAVE THE BABY --
NO MATTER WHAT THE CIRCUMSTANCES
WOULD BE WHETHER WE FELT WE ARE
MAYBE READY OR NOT BUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF ROE V. WADE WAS
THAT IT GIVES US GAVE US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THAT CHOICE.
AND THAT'S WHERE ALL THE WEIGHT
IS ABOUT AS HAVE HAVING THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO CHOOSE FOR
YOURSELF I AGREE AS A MAN I
THINK IT'S IT'S JUST NONE OF MY
BUSINESS TO TELL A WOMAN WHAT
THEY CAN AND CAN'T DO WITH THEIR
BODY THAT IS JUST NOT MY
BUSINESS.
AND TO TO NOW HAVE THE SITUATION
THAT WE HAVE --
RIGHT NOW WITH THIS ISSUE COMING
BACK UP YOU JUST NEED TO
REMEMBER THAT.
THIS DOESN'T SAY THAT EVERYONE
HAS TO BE PRO CHOICE THIS ROBY
WAY GIVES EVERYBODY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THAT
DECISION FOR THEMSELVES YOU WANT
TO BE PRO LIFE.
YOU CAN BE PRO LIFE YOU CAN BE
PRO LIFE WITHIN YOUR OWN FAMILY
AND MAKE THAT CHOICE TO NOT GET
AN ABORTION IF YOU WANT TO BE
CHOICE AND YOU WANT.
TO X. EXPERIENCE OR NOT
EXPERIENCE BUT MAKE THE DECISION.
TO GET AN ABORTION YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT TO MAKE THAT CHOICE AND
THAT'S WHAT THE LAW SHOULD BE.
TO TO ALLOW YOU TO MAKE THAT
CHOICE FOR YOURSELF AS AN
INDIVIDUAL TO ALLOW YOU TO
DISCUSS THAT WITH YOUR FAMILY
AND MAKE THAT DECISION WITHIN
YOUR FAMILY.
AND I CANNOT THINK OF SOMETHING
MORE INAPPROPRIATE FOR A
GOVERNMENT TO DO THAN TO COME
INTO YOUR BEDROOM IN TO MAKE
THAT DECISION FOR YOU.
OR TO TAKE THAT DECISION AWAY
FROM YOU SO I I OBVIOUSLY
SUPPORT ROE V. WADE AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THIS BODY AND
FOR THE STATE TO RECOGNIZE ITS
IMPORTANCE NOT JUST IN THE STATE
BUT NATIONALLY.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE [inaudible]
MR STONE.
YOUR RECORD.
THANK YOU.
AS AN ALL WHITE MAN I THINK I
NEED TO EXPLAIN --
MAYBE.
MAYBE MAYBE NOT [inaudible]
IT.
BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE OUR OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO SPEAKING
ABOUT CHOICE.
AND SPEAKING ABOUT THE JOURNEY
THAT HIS FAMILY WENT THROUGH.
BECAUSE REALIZE MOST WOMEN FACE
WITH THIS CHOICE.
DON'T CHOOSE AN ABORTION.
AND IN FACT WE HEARD THIS BILL.
IN THE COMMITTEE I WAS KIND OF
ASTONISHED AT THE OPPOSITION
BECAUSE THE OPPOSITION WAS
REALLY MORE FOCUSED ON PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
AND THEY USED THE TERM THAT WAS
REALLY NEW TO ME THE ABORTION
INDUSTRY.
WHICH WAS A REAL LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S WHAT'S AT
STAKE.
AND WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE
BECAUSE WHAT PLANNED PARENTHOOD
PROVIDES.
IS SOME OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
LOW COST.
HEALTH SERVICES IN OUR COMMUNITY
TO THOSE WHO HAVE NOT HAD HEALTH
SERVICES.
IT'S NOT ACTUALLY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE.
WHAT I APPLIED PLANNED
PARENTHOOD FOR BEING ONE OF THE
FEW VENUES?
THAT ACTUALLY PROVIDES CHOICE
[inaudible] TWO ONE THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S ABOUT WHAT ROE VERSUS
WADE IS ABOUT.
IS SAYING FOR THE GOVERNMENT TO
GET OUT OF THE DECISION.
PROBABLY THE MOST DIFFICULT
DECISION A WOMAN HAS TO MAY.
AND TO THINK THAT SHE IS NOT
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT.
THE ON BOARD THE CHILD THAT SHE
IS CARED IF THE THINK SHE
DOESN'T HAVE THAT CONNECTION
[inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
IS.
AS I'M TOLD AND AS HIVE LEARNED.
COMPLETELY UNTRUE.
SO FOR US TO STAND HERE AS A
BODY AS MEN.
WE SHOULD BE DEFERRING TO THE
STORIES TO THE PERSPECTIVES TO
THE EMOTION THAT'S INVOLVED.
AND NOT TAKE ANY OF IT FOR
GRANTED.
ROE VERSUS WADE WHICH IS UNDER
ASSAULT AND THERE ARE IN FACT
MANY RIGHTS.
BETTER UNDER ASSAULT THE
CALIFORNIA'S TRYING TO PROTECT
OF OUR PEOPLE.
WHICH IS WHY WE WORK SO HARD THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SPACE ON THE
CHILD WELFARE SPACE ON SO MANY
OTHER THINGS TAKE TAKE TAKE CARE
OF FAMILIES.
THAT DO MAKE THAT DECISION. TO
HAVE A CHILD AND WHO STRUGGLE
WITH BEING ABLE TO RAISE THAT
CHILD.
SO WE NEED TO SUPPORT.
PEOPLE'S DECISIONS TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR OWN
SELVES AND THEIR OWN BODIES
THAT'S REALLY WHAT ROE V. WADE
IS ABOUT IT'S REALLY.
THE SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF IT IT'S
REALLY ALL IT IS ABOUT IS ABOUT
CHOICE.
AND WHO GETS TO MAKE THAT CHOICE.
SO I STAND SUPPORT OF HR.
SIX ALL DISCUSSION AND DEBATE.
ON THE RESOLUTION HAVING SEIZE.
MISTER MONEY MAY CLOSE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TODAY WE'VE HEARD OTHER
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION WITH
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES DIFFERENT
VOICES.
BUT THE THEMES ARE THE
IMPORTANCE OF CHOICE.
AND HOW MUCH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO STAND%
BEHIND OUR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
AS WOMEN TO MAKE THAT CHOICE NO
MATTER HOW COMPLICATED.
OR HARD THAT DECISION CAN BE IT
IS OUR DECISION.
IT'S ALSO THE FORTY SIX YEAR
ANNIVERSARY.
AND EVERY YEAR WE AS WOMEN RISE
AND STAND AND HAVE TO REMIND
PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE FOUGHT.
THAT WE HAVE WORKED REALLY HARD
TO HAVE THE RIGHT TO MAKE THIS
DECISION.
NEXT YEAR WILL LIKELY NOT BE THE
EXCEPTION.
AS WE LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND THE
RHETORIC AND THE CONVERSATIONS.
AND THE VERY REAL THREAT THAT
THIS RATE MAY BE TAKEN AWAY FROM
US.
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
REASSURE THE STATE AND THE
TWENTY MILLION WOMEN IN THIS
STATE.
THAT WE WILL FIGHT FOR THIS FOR
THIS CHOICE.
AND FOR THAT MEMBERS I ASKED WE
WILL I ON THIS RESOLUTION.
AND IS THE MOMENT YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THE AUTHORS YOUR QUESTION THE
FIRST ROLL.
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON H. R.
SIX FOUR CLUB IN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO OFFERS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE THERE FIFTY NINE CO
AUTHORS ADDED WE WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTES ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF A
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
EYES FIFTY NINE KNOWS FOURTEEN
THAT RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
I WOULD LIKE.
TO THEY CAN KNOWLEDGE
[inaudible]
THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TYLER DEEP
CELEBRATED A BIRTHDAY.
OVER THE WEEKEND HAPPY BIRTHDAY
SIR.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
WEDNESDAY JANUARY TWENTY THIRD
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY.
JANUARY TWENTY FOURTH FLOOR
SESSION.
IS AT NINE AM IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED WE WILL.
NOW MOVE.
TO I'VE BEEN CORRECTED WE ARE
NOT LIFTING THE QUORUM CALL.
FORM CALL STAYS IN PLACE.
THAT'S MISTER CALDERON IS RIGHT
OVER THERE.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
WERE AT ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
[inaudible]
THE GERMANS.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR.
SEE YOU MAY GIVE YOU RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES
WILL BE A TURNING IN THE MEMORY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
DOCTOR WHAT YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
JOURNEY THE MEMORY OF JEREMIAH
CURRENT THE FATHER OF MY STAFF
MEMBER NICOLE CURRENT SANCHEZ.
JERRY AS HE WAS KNOWN TO
EVERYONE WAS AN INCREDIBLE
HUMBLE AND GENEROUS MAN WHO
WORKED HIS WAY UP THE LADDER
STARTING AS A DISHWASHER.
AND A LINE COOK AND A SOUS CHEF.
AND RESPECTED PASTRY CHEF AND
EVENTUALLY THE PROUD OWNER OF A
SUCCESSFUL BAKERY IN SANTA ANA
FOR THIRTY SIX YEARS.
HE LOVED HIS FAMILY HE LOVED HIS
WORK.
HE WORKED HARD WAS A
COMPASSIONATE EMPLOYER TAKING
GOOD CARE OF HIS STAFF.
JERRY NEVER WORE A WATCH AND
SOMETIMES THAT GOT HIM INTO
TROUBLE.
WEDNESDAY'S WERE SPEND FOR TO
WORK FOR SPENDING TIME WITH HIS
CHILDREN TAKING INTO THE BEACH
OR TO DISNEYLAND.
OFTEN BRING THEM HOME LATE FOR
DINNER MUCH TO HIS WIFE'S
INDUSTRY GRAHAM.
HE LOVES MUSIC MOSTLY ROCK AND
ROLL FROM THE SIXTIES AND
SEVENTIES AND SINGING ALONG WITH
IT.
HE LOVED DOGS IN AND RESCUED
MANY HAVING AS MANY AS FIVE AT
ONE TIME.
HE WAS A HUGE FOOTBALL AND
BASEBALL FAN THE ANGELS WERE HIS
TEAM.
HE TAUGHT AS CHILDREN THE
IMPORTANCE OF KINDNESS AND
FRIENDSHIP TO ALWAYS TREAT
OTHERS WITH RESPECT AND DIGNITY
TO ALWAYS SMILE AND SAY HELLO TO
A STRANGER.
JERRY PASSED AWAY ON DECEMBER
TWENTY EIGHTH AND IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE.
OF FORTY THREE YEARS CINDY.
HIS DAUGHTER NICOLE HIS SON ERIC
IS GRANDSON CREWS HIS IN LAWS
LYDIA NOW FRED IN HIS SON IN LAW
RICK.
I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY.
TO THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD.
THIS MELENDEZ.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN I RISE SAY DO
DURING AN MEMORY OF KENNEDY JUNE
BOND RYAN.
CAME WAS BORN JANUARY TWELFTH
TWO THOUSAND ONE IN FULLERTON
CALIFORNIA AND TRAGICALLY LOST
HER LIFE ON OCTOBER THIRTEENTH
OF LAST YEAR --
AFTER A FATAL CAR ACCIDENT.
SHE IS OFTEN REMEMBERED FOR
BEING A SHINING LIGHT IN
PEOPLE'S AYE IN PEOPLE'S LIVES
AND THAT BREAK BEAMING SMILE
THAT COULD BE SEEN FROM FAR FAR
AWAY.
SHE WOULD ALWAYS HAVE HER PRETTY
BLONDE HAIR UP IN A BUN ON HER
HEAD WHEN SHE WAS IN THE POLL.
I'M KENNEDY PLAYED WATER POLO
AND SWIM WITH MY DAUGHTER WENT
TO HIGH SCHOOL WITH MY BOYS
SITTING IN IN OCTOBER --
IT WAS RAINING SHE WAS GOING
DOWN A RIVER CANYON AND SOMEHOW
LOST CONTROL OF THE VEHICLE --
AND AND HIT A POLE AND DIED AM.
SHE WAS THE YOUNGEST CHILD IN
THE RYAN FAMILY SHE WAS THE BABY --
SHE WAS KNOWN FOR LAUGHING ALL
THE TIME IS MOSTLY AT TIMES WHEN
SHE PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
LAUGHING --
FOR STEALING HER OLDER SISTER
CURRENTS CLOTHING --
AND JUST FOR BEING A KIND KIND
SOUL.
KENNEDY WAS A GIRL SCOUT SHE WAS
IN CHOIR SHE WAS IN PAGEANTS
USING DRILL TEAM SHE'S A WATER
POLO IF THERE'S SOMETHING TO BE
INVOLVED IN SHE WAS IN IT.
AND I WILL TELL YOU ONE THING
ABOUT KENNY THAT ALWAYS ITEMIZED
HER CHARACTER CHOOSE A FIERCE.
WATER POLO PLAYER SHE WAS A
BEAST IN THE WATER YOU DID NOT
WANT TO MESS WITH HER YOU
CERTAINLY DIDN'T WANT HAVE TO
GUARD HER.
AND ONE OF THE GAMES THEY WERE
WAY AHEAD TO MY SCHOOL'S TEAM
WAS WAY AHEAD AND THE COACH HAD
THE KIND OF YELL AT KENNEDY A
LITTLE BIT LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT
ARE YOU DOING BECAUSE SHE WAS
ACTUALLY TEACHING THE GIRL WHO
IS TRYING TO GUARD HER.
HOW TO GUARD HER BETTER?
SHE WAS THAT KIND OF KIND
HEARTED PERSON --
SHE HAS TWO BROTHERS AT LEAVE.
SHE LEAVES BEHIND HER MOM
KIMBERLY HERE'S A DEAR FRIEND OF
MINE HER FATHER HARVEY ALSO A
FRIEND HER BROTHER'S LEVI AND
HIS WIFE JILLIAN HER BROTHER
GARRETT HER SISTER OF COURSE
KARAN -- YOU
KNOW I WILL I HONESTLY THERE ARE
ARE DEALT THAT I KNOW THAT
HAVEN'T LIVED IS GOOD --
OF AN EXAMPLE AS FAR AS OUR LIFE
AS KENNEDY DID IN HER SEVENTEEN
SHORE YEARS.
SHE WAS KIND SHE WAS CHEERFUL.
SHE JUST I DON'T KNOW SHE WAS.
SHE REALLY WAS A BRIGHT LIGHT IN
EVEN.
EVEN IN HER DEATH SHE CONTINUED
TO GIVE BECAUSE WHEN KENNY ARE
DRIVERS LICENSE SHE DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT A DONOR WISE SO WHEN SHE
WAS FILLING OUT THE PAPERWORK
SHASTA MOM WHAT IS THIS DONOR DO
YOU WANT TO BE A DONOR.
AND HER MOM EXPLAINED TO HER
WHAT THAT IS IN KENNEDY'S
RESPONSE WAS WILL YEAH WHY WOULD
I WANT TO HELP SOMEONE.
SO WHEN WE WENT TO HER MEMORIAL
SERVICE WE TALKED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT.
EVEN IN DEATH KENNEDY WAS GIVING
BACK AND IN BY.
HER BEING SUCH A GREAT EXAMPLE
BECAUSE YOU KNOW HER EYES NOW.
THOUGH VIEWED BY SOMEONE ELSE
WILL SEE THE BEAUTY OF THE
SUNSET THE BEAUTY OF THE OCEAN
PERHAPS.
THE BEAUTY OF THEIR OWN CHILDREN
BEING BORN HER HEART THERE WILL
BE IN SOMEONE ELSE'S BODY WILL
SWELL WITH LOVE AND PRIDE --
AT THEIR OWN FAMILY AND THIS IS
A LEGACY THAT CONTINUES FOR
KENNEDY I CANNOT IMAGINE.
WHAT IT FEELS LIKE TO YOU TO
LOSE A CHILD IT'S ONLY SEVENTEEN
YEARS OLD?
I DON'T THINK ANY OF US CAN --
BUT I NO FROM THOSE OF US WHO
KNEW HER THAT WE'RE BLESSED TO
HAVE KNOWN HER AND AND THANKFUL
TO HAVE HAD HER IN OUR LIVES SO
WITH THAT I WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE JORDAN
HER MEMORY TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS MELENDEZ MS QUIRK
SILVA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I HAVE
TO ADJOURN TO MEMORIES FIRST --
I AM GOING TO BE SPEAKING ABOUT
FRED MASON AND HE WAS VERY
ACTIVE IN FULLERTON COMMUNITY
LIFE HE WAS A BOARD MEMBER OF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT I
WORKED FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS.
AND THAT FULLER TEN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
IN ADDITION TO THAT HE SERVED IN.
OUR UNITED STATES MILITARY IN
GERMANY HE ALSO.
BECAME A LAWYER A WHERE HE DID
THAT AS HIS PROFESSION FOR MANY
MANY YEARS AFTER RETIRING HE GOT
EVEN MORE INVOLVED IN ADDITION
TO BEING A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER.
HE DECIDED THAT AN OLD LIBRARY
AND FULLER TEN SHOULD BE SAVED
AND WAS ONE OF THE FORCES BEHIND
TURNING THAT INTO A FULLER TEN
MUSEUM WHICH CONTINUES TODAY.
HE IS LEFT.
OR HE HAS LEFT BEHIND HIS WIFE
JOYCE AND HIS THREE DAUGHTERS --
PAM WHO IS NOW A FILMMAKER IN
NEW YORK.
UP.
HIS OTHER DAUGHTER WHO IS LAUREL
WHO TEACHES ACTUALLY IN LA HABRA
HEIGHTS IN AS WORK WITH MANY OF
OUR ENGLISH LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT
STUDENTS.
AND MAUREEN WHO IS A PROFESSOR
AND LONG BEACH SO I ASKED THAT
WE KEEP FRED AND HIS FAMILY IN
YOUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS AND
THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA AND
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR NEXT
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF RAYMOND WILLIAM J.
SO WHO WAS BORN ON NOVEMBER
FOURTEENTH NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
AND DIED THIS OCTOBER.
NINTH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN HE DIED IN A AND
A TRAFFIC ACCIDENT HE WAS HIT BY
A CAR.
AND I'M REALLY GOING TO BE
SHARING.
UP BILLY STORY AND BILLY STORY
IS A STORY THAT IS UNLIKE MANY
OF OUR STORIES HERE WHERE WE IN
GERMAN AND MEMORY.
MANY TIMES WHEN WE INJURE AND
AND A MEMORY OF SOMEBODY THEY
HAVE ACCOMPLISHED MUCH IN THEIR
LIFE.
THEY HAVE OF MADE IS PROUD THEY
HAVE FAMILY THAT.
WANTS.
TO BE THERE FOR SERVICE OR A FEW
THE STORY IS LIKE THAT OF
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS AND
ACROSS THE WORLD SOMEBODY WHO
DOESN'T FEEL FITS THAT BILLING.
HE WAS EIGHTY SAID IN A LINE OF
TEN CHILDREN.
HE WAS VERY ACTIVE AND ATHLETIC.
HE WAS FUNNY HE WAS SMART BUT
EARLY ON IN HIS CHILDHOOD HE HAD
DIFFICULTIES IN SCHOOL HE OFTEN
WAS DISCIPLINE.
AS A TEACHER MYSELF I THINK BACK
THAT HE PROBABLY DID HAVE ADHD
BUT WAS NOT DIAGNOSED.
HE WAS BORN TO A TEENAGE MOTHER.
WHO HAD TEN CHILDREN AND IN THE
TIME THAT HE WAS BORN IN THE
SIXTIES MANY TIMES?
FAMILIES AT THAT TIME DIDN'T
FEEL THAT THEY COULD.
APPROACH SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
ASK FOR TESTING AGAIN AS A
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD MOTHER --
SHE DID LISTEN TO WHAT THE
TEACHER SAID SO HE WOULD BE
DISCIPLINE NORMALLY AT SCHOOL
BUT MANY TIMES AT HOME.
THIS LED TO NOT ONLY ISSUES IN
SCHOOL BUT EARLY INTERFACING
WITH THE JUVENILE DEPARTMENT
WHERE.
HE STARTED A PATTERN OF GOING IN
AND OUT OF THE JUVENILE SYSTEM
AND THAT CONTINUED REALLY THE
REST OF HIS LIFE.
BILLY WAS SOMEBODY WHO HAD A
YOUNG BOY BEFORE HE WAS EIGHTEEN
AND LATER A DAUGHTER.
BUT BECAUSE OF HIS IN IN NOW
WITH THE JUVENILE SYSTEM.
AND BECAUSE OF HIS ADDICTION
ISSUES OF ALCOHOL.
HIS LIFE CONTINUED ON A PATTERN
OF A DOT DOWN WORLD SPIRAL.
AND WITH MANY MANY FAMILY
MEMBERS TRYING TO INTERVENE AT
EVERY STEP POSSIBLE.
THERE WAS NO CURE OR FOR SOMEONE
WITH CHRONIC ADDICTION
ALCOHOLISM.
WHICH FOR MANY OF US WHO HAVE
SUFFERED THAT IN FAMILIES WE
KNOW IT IS A DISEASE.
BUT WHAT WE SEE NOW IS THAT.
WE HAVE PEOPLE GOING IN AND OUT
OF OUR EMERGENCY ROOMS WE HAVE
PEOPLE GOING IN AND OUT OF UP
PERHAPS SOME TYPE OF SOBER
LIVING AND YET.
THEY DON'T RECOVER.
BILLY SUFFERED WITH ADDITIONAL
ISSUES BECAUSE IF YOU'VE BEEN ON
A CHRONIC ALCOHOL.
OF ALCOHOLIC YOU WOULD HAVE
ISSUES WITH YOUR HEALTH FROM
LIVER DISEASE TO IS OUR EYES. TO
ALSO A HERNIA AS BILLY AGE TO
CONTINUED IN THE SYSTEM.
AND HOMELESSNESS BECAME AN EVEN
GREATER ISSUE AS HIS MOTHER.
MY MOTHER.
DID EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO BE BY
HIS SIDE THERE STILL WAS NOT A
PLACE AS SHE LIVED IN --
A SENIOR CONDO.
SO EVEN WITH HER TRYING TO HELP
HIM SHE WOULD GET LETTER SAYING
HE COULDN'T STAY THERE WE ALL
TRY TO HELP ALL OF MY BROTHERS
AND SISTERS.
AND BILLIE STORY IS NOT UNIQUE
WE SEE THIS EVERY DAY ON OUR
STREETS AND MY PLAYED TO US IS
TO LOOK AT THOSE PEOPLE. TO KNOW
THEIR STORIES TO UNDERSTAND THAT
WE HAVE TO DO MORE AND SO AS I
STAND ON THIS FLOOR.
BEGINNING MY THIRTEEN THIRD TERM
I CAN TELL YOU I WILL CONTINUE
TO FIGHT UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
HOMELESSNESS ISSUES AND I WILL
NOT SHRINK WHEN PEOPLE SAY.
WELL WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING ELSE
FOR THEM OR THEY DON'T BELONG
HERE OR IT COSTS TOO MUCH WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THIS AS A
STATE AND AS A COUNTRY BECAUSE
BILLY STORY IS OUR STORY.
IT YOUR STORY MY STORY AND I ASK
YOU TO UP.
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF MY
BROTHER BILLY.
THANK YOU REST QUIRK SILVA.
MR GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
GERMANY MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
THIS AFTERNOON TO ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN THE IN MEMORY OF FORMER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND SAN DIEGO
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE LARRY CAP
LAW.
JUDGE KAPPLE OFF WAS BORN ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTY SECOND NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE IN BROOKLYN NEW YORK.
HE GREW UP IN A BLUE COLLAR
NEIGHBORHOOD KEANSBURG NEW
JERSEY WHERE HE LEARNED HOW TO
SELL.
VACUUMS DOOR TO DOOR.
AS AN ACTIVIST AT AN EARLY AGE
HE BEGAN WALKING PRECINCTS ON
BEHALF OF DEMOCRATIC PARTY
CANDIDATES AT THE AGE OF JUST.
TWELVE MADE HIS WAY OUT TO
CALIFORNIA AFTER SERVING TWO
YEARS IN THE UNITED STATES ARMY
DURING THE KOREAN WAR AND
ULTIMATELY GRADUATED FROM
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA LOS
ANGELES.
TRUE TO HIS ACTIVISTS ROOTS
JUDGE CAP OFF DECIDED TO RUN
AGAINST A FIVE TERM INCUMBENT
FOR THE SEVENTY EIGHT THE SIMPLY
DISTRICT A SEAT THAT MOST PEOPLE
AT THAT TIME CONSIDERED BE
LOCKED UP.
IN CITY NO CHANCE OF FLIPPING.
HE WON HE WON THAT RACE IN ONLY
THE FLIP THE SEAT FROM
REPUBLICAN TO DEMOCRATIC HANDS
FOR DECADE HE LAID THE
GROUNDWORK FOR DEMOCRATIC
ACTIVISM ALONG CALIFORNIA'S
COASTLINE.
DURING THIS TIME I IN THIS BODY
HE TACKLE SOME OF THE STATE'S
BIGGEST ISSUES WATER TAXES THE
ENVIRONMENT AND PUSH FOR
MEASURES HELPING SENIORS KIDNEY
DIALYSIS PATIENTS.
AND SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS.
AFTER A DECADE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE A HE WAS APPOINTED
TO THE SAN DIEGO SUPERIOR COURT
OFTEN JOINED MIXED REACTIONS
FROM ATTORNEYS.
PROSECUTORS OFTEN FELT THAT HE
WAS TOO LENIENT WHILE DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS APPRECIATED HIS
WILLINGNESS TO GIVE THEIR
CLIENTS A SECOND CHANCE CHANCE.
HE RETIRED FROM THE BENCH IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE BUT
CONTINUED HIS TOUR CASES AS A
SENIOR JUDGE.
AND THE JUNE ALL COURT FOR MANY
YEARS AFTER HIS RETIREMENT.
AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY NINE HE
PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY TWELFTH
AT HIS HOME CONSCRIPTS RANCH.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS DAUGHTER
YVONNE SANCHEZ OF SAN DIEGO HIS
SON NORMAN AND HIS WIFE ANGELA
OF SAN DIEGO. SIX GRANDCHILDREN
AND THREE GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
SAN DIEGO IS BETTER BECAUSE HIS
SERVICE MY WRIST TWO GERMAN IN
HIS MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA THANK
YOU MEMBERS ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SINGING THERE ARE NO FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER KALRA MOOSE MISTER BRO
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY JANUARY
TWENTY FOURTH.
LIFTED